why is godzilla
attacking everything in sight that is
the one question that has puzzled most
of us fans from the first time they saw
the trailer
more than two weeks back well right here
on minecube we are going to discuss
why godzilla seems to be going after
apex and monarch sites everywhere in the
world
as if he is in search of something and
that is the topic of the day
what is godzilla really searching for
there are three possible things that has
the king of the monsters attention
and it could be either one of them or
all of them
but before we go in depth give it up to
my man methylkaijufan97
he does awesome animation work on his
channel do check them out
and subscribe to him and of course
subscribe to our channel too
so let's get to it well let's see
godzilla's personality and behavior
first
oh well his behavior is that of a
territorial animal
ishiro serizawa theorized that godzilla
to be the driving force to restore
balance to nature whenever that balance
is disrupted
suggesting that he essentially considers
the entire earth
to be his territory however unlike
previous incarnations
godzilla doesn't blatantly attack or
plow through buildings and ships at sea
simply because they're there in fact
with larger ships like the aircraft
carrier
he simply dives down under them monarch
considers him
and others like behemoth and mothra as
protected titans
which means their true behavior is to
defend the world and restore the natural
order of things
furthermore in the monster verse
godzilla was designed to have a
personality that would evoke
the last samurai archetype an ancient
warrior contend with solitude and
preferring not to be a part of the world
but has to resurface when certain types
of events force him to appear
and set things right although this noble
persona of him is of high regard
godzilla also has some degree of rivalry
with other titans like monster zero
or also known as king ghidorah and a
long history and an ancient rivalry
with a species of kong and mutos as he
is depicted fighting alternatively with
one of them in various cave paintings
following ghidorah's death godzilla
starts to care for the well-being of the
human race
as evidenced by a clipping in the end
credits mentioning that godzilla is
keeping the other titans
from attacking major human settlements
so with that in mind why would godzilla
suddenly attack
and destroy multiple military sites and
apex bases
as well as monarch stations around the
world well the most logical reason for
this
is that he is in search or desperately
searching for something
something that can emit a biosignature
that would capture his interest
after all godzilla isn't a telephotic
being he can't sense
anything with his mind he can sense
things he can't sense things with esp or
the sixth sense but he does have a very
evolved sense that can capture and track
bio signatures or bio acoustics that are
emitted by other titans
in fact all the titans have that sense
case in point
godzilla was seen tracking the murder
signatures in 2014
he was also seen doing the same in 2019
for ghidorah
and rodan and the other titans were also
attracted to the orca
in king of the monsters so in this movie
this biosignature thing will play a very
important role in
determining the hidden plot that's
provoking the g-man and turning the
world against him
well there are three possible things
that he is going after
and we are going to discuss them now
starting with the first
godzilla senses new titan signatures as
we have seen in the news clippings at
the end credit scenes of godzilla king
of the monsters
the tiny print layout in the section of
the newspaper hints that
monarch or other human agencies had
already tried to create organic titans
biotins and this was the cause of
several
titan incidents and with apex a new
organization that deals with robotics
and cybernetics
it could be that they are testing such
things in various facilities spread
around the globe
and due to that new and unnatural
biosignatures are made
which would trigger godzilla to hunt
them down and put an end to a possibly
new threat
to the planet as perceived by the g-man
or it could be that
the apex group intentionally sounds out
these
acoustics in order to tame the image of
godzilla attacking human human
settlements
and then this would turn the entire
world against the titan
second the most common theory out there
right now is godzilla is in search of
ghidorah's remaining head and the brain
waves of mechagodzilla that is in fact
really ghidorah's signature
as we have discussed in our earlier
videos the frame
the body frame for mechagodzilla in
theory could be constructed from the
bones of dagon
a deceased member of godzilla species
that died out fighting the muto prime
but that is just a body the brain and
the functioning systems however could be
made functional with the integration of
ghidorah's remaining head
the one that was bitten off in the
battle of the of the course of mexico
the name is kevin so apex could be
activating or researching parts of
ghidorah's head
which in turn creates brain waves and
biosignatures that attracts godzilla
towards them
godzilla however only reacts to
ghidorah's signature and
attacks only to destroy whatever remains
of his nemesis
lastly godzilla might be searching for
the mysterious act that was discovered
by monarch
the one that was shown in the end
credits scenes in news clippings of
godzilla king of the monsters what this
egg is is yet unknown but the news
clippings say that
monarch finds a massive egg and that an
expeditionary team deep into mothra's
territory finds a giant egg
and this has been transported to an
unknown monarch facility
the monsterverse incarnation of mothra
returns the character to her touhou
incarnations
as a mystical being of resurrection
being capable of returning from death
by laying an egg from which she is
reborn as a lava
when her previous form dies out and as
we know by
now godzilla mothra shares a very deep
symbiotic relationship
could this be the reason godzilla is
attacking military and apex bases
is he searching for the next mothra and
ensuring the
species lives on and with the world
experimenting on ghidorah's head
creating mechanized titans and also
trying to create biotitans as well
in the process creating new
biosignatures and killing them
off when they fail to activate properly
a baby mothra's voice in this chaotic
time
would of course get a reply from the
king of the monsters
and he would be going to rescue his
future queen just as mothra
guided sarizawa and his team to the
location of godzilla
in order to revive him for the fight
against monster zero
godzilla vs kong might see the nuclear
lizard returning the favor
and rescuing the egg from monarch or
apex
and could these organization actually
use the mothra sound
to lure in godzilla into a fight against
gong well
this is the right question and so with
that we come to the
end of the video on what godzilla is
searching for
it could be three things that he's
attracted to
with an intent to destroy and also to
save it it could be the
new bio signatures from titans being
created by humans
or apex or monarch or whatever agency
that's there or renzerizawa the yi
the yi as haircut boy
it could be the brainwaves of ghidorah
attracting him
which would mean he is in search of
mechagodzilla unknowingly
and lastly he could be in search for
mothra herself
and combining with the other two he
could be on a mission to retrieve the
egg
or all the three things at once gotta
catch them all
so subscribe for more most of verse
videos and godzilla vs congress sections
also like for support and slap slap slap
that bell button for regular updates
on what's new take care fam